the news of the day is that rochester
officers are not going to be charged in
the death
of daniel prude so you may remember the
daniel pruitt case it was another one of
these cases where the tape
looks really unpleasant but the reality
is that the officers are
almost certainly not responsible for the
death of daniel prude
it created riots during the black lives
matter
situation during the summer in rochester
particularly
this came out kind of late in the summer
because originally
the daniel pruitt died in march but then
the tape didn't come out until a couple
of months later it became just another
one of the names that is
listed in the litany of people who are
supposedly murdered by the police
many of those names don't belong on that
list right jacob blake was put on that
list he's not dead but
he was put on the list he was
responsible for the riots in kenosha it
turned out that he had
a knife in his hand when he was refusing
to obey the
orders of officers it turns out not all
of these cases are exactly the same and
daniel prude falls into the category
of a case where it is absolutely unclear
that the officers killed him in fact the
evidence tends to show
the opposite according to the new york
times on a snowy night last march daniel
pruitt sprinted shirtless out of his
brother's home in rochester new york
seemingly in the grip of a psychotic
episode distraught his brother called
police for help
instead the officers handcuffed mr prude
placed a mesh hood over his head and
pressed him into the pavement until he
lost consciousness
okay now that is a wild exaggeration of
the actual chain of events
so we actually have the tape right the
police tape came out of what happened
here
and daniel prude is walking down the
street in the middle of rochester
it is snowing outside and he is
completely nude
at the time and he starts shouting at
the officers give me your gun
and so they restrain him and then he
starts trying to spit
at them and he says that he is coveted
positive remember this is early on in
the pandemic
this is like two weeks into the shutdown
of the pandemic
and so they do what officers are trained
to do they put a mesh hood on him it is
breathable
did not put him in a burlap sack they
didn't choke him to death
okay and then it appears that he died of
excited delirium and because it turns
out that he was probably extremely high
on pcp
that is what the autopsy showed again he
was walking naked down the street
in rochester so this obviously was not
somebody who was in a
decent mental or physical condition when
the officers first encountered him
here's a little bit of what that tape
looked like
get on the ground man look get on the
ground put your hands behind your back
behind your back don't move don't move
chill out man don't move i mean it god
bless y'all man
get them away from about me in jesus
christ i pray
amen
you hear them say give me that gun and
then they and then they put him and they
hold him down because he is not staying
down right
that mesh hood is breathable and then at
a certain point he says that
he can't breathe which is true because
he can't breathe he's suffering from
excited delirium
the autopsy said that he was
experiencing excited delirium which is a
condition that often follows heavy drug
use
similar autopsy report was made about
for example george floyd in minneapolis
the autopsy tends to show that he did
not die as a direct result of the
officer's
pressure in that particular case that he
was high on fentanyl at the time
something similar happened here with
daniel prude according to the best
available scientific reports
according to the new york times miss
james leticia james
who is the who is the attorney general
of the state of new york she said she
was extremely disappointed with the
grand jury which is always a good move
it's always a good move when you have
officers of the law saying they are
disappointed with the workings of the
law
in any case on tuesday the new york
attorney general leticia james announced
none of the officers who arrested prude
would face charges in connection with
his death
a grand jury convened by james to
investigate the case declined to charge
any of the seven officers on the scene
that night with a crime
miss james said the criminal justice
system has demonstrated an unwillingness
to hold law enforcement
enforcement officers accountable in the
unjustified killing of african americans
what binds these cases is the tragic
loss of life in circumstances
in which the death could have been
avoided if she has a way that people can
escape
dying from excited delirium i would love
to hear it seriously
in an unusual move a monroe county court
judge karen bailey turner on tuesday
evening granted the attorney general's
request to release minutes
related to the grand jury's
investigation records that are generally
protected under seal miss james said the
public deserves to know what transpires
behind closed doors which of course
defeats the purpose of a blind jury
system the date to make the documents
public
has not been set the federal doj says
they might open a civil rights
investigation into the officers
they've tried this before under barack
obama usually it fails you'll remember
that it was eric holder's
doj that refused to incite george
zimmerman in the death of trayvon martin
for example on tuesday evening a crowd
of about 150 people marched through the
city denouncing the grand jury decision
in the system
that made it possible the system that
made it possible you mean like
trial by by jury and grand jury process
and due process of law that that system
according to the new york times after
body camera video of mr prude's death
became public in the fall
his name now joined a now familiar list
of black people killed during
interactions with police including
george floyd whose death in minneapolis
led to months of demonstrations
nationwide particularly unsettling in
the case of mr were images of him
in a hood reminiscent of the ones used
in lynching of black people that is not
what happened
these police officers did not arrive on
scene and decide you know what let's
lynch this guy
he started spitting at them yelling at
them and he was coveted positive at that
point
again we were two weeks into the
pandemic at this point so they put a
spit hood on him
which is a mesh hood that you can
breathe through
the rochester police locust club which
is the union that represents the city's
700 law enforcement officers declined to
comment on the grand jury's decision
naturally leticia james suggested that
there had to be sweeping reforms and how
the police interact with and are trained
to deal with people in emotional
distress
buried in this article from the new york
times are the actual circumstances here
mr prude 41 lived in chicago but had vis
had been visiting his brother in
rochester
friends said that before his death mr
prude begun to rely more heavily on the
drug pcp
this is one of the more dangerous drugs
known to man known as angel dust it can
cause erratic behavior he began to use
drugs they said to cope with the 2018
death by suicide of his nephew with whom
he had lived
the day before the episode his brother
joe had him hospitalized at strong
memorial hospital for a psychiatric
evaluation but he was sent home hours
later so if you're going to put blame
anywhere it ought to be with the
psychiatric hospital that released this
guy
because by the next night he was out on
the street wandering around naked in the
snow
and shouting at police officers that he
wanted their gun and that he had covered
while trying to spit at them
just hours after returning from the
hospital on march 23rd mr prude suddenly
burst from his brother's home and ran
into the night
fearful for his safety his brother
called 9-1-1
and people obviously fear the police so
much that they call 9-1-1 when they have
a problem
worried proof might inadvertently harm
himself or run across nearby train
tracks
police who answered the call found
proved naked and reported he had told at
least one passerby he had covered
when they apprehended him he began
spitting and the officers responded by
pulling the metroid over his head
when he tried to rise the officers
forced mr proved face down on the ground
one of them pushed his head to the
pavement police body camera footage
showed
the police held proof down for two
minutes he had to be resuscitated he
died at the hospital a week later
okay now again the reality of the
autopsy is that he
likely died of his drug intake and
excited delirium which is a condition
that often follows
heavy drug use one of the symptoms of
excited delirium is that you feel
overheated which might be one of the
reasons why he shed all of his clothes
in the middle of the night in rochester
when it was freezing outside and snowing
a deputy police chief in rochester wrote
in a june 4th email to his supervisor
saying we certainly do not want people
to misinterpret the officer's actions
and conflate this incident with any
recent killings of unarmed black men by
law enforcement nationally that would
simply be a false narrative and could
create animosity and potentially violent
blowback in the community
as a result the new york times
interpreted that letter as an attempted
cover-up
as opposed to the police saying you guys
are going to misinterpret the tape and
then everybody going and misinterpreting
the tape
late last year the offices the city's
office of public integrity
apparently concluded no wrongdoing had
been committed by any city employee
miss james suggested daniel prude was in
the throes of a mental health crisis
what he needed was compassion care and
helped from trained professionals
tragically he received none of those
things he literally was at the hospital
the day before and they discharged him
so people are using this as yet another
example of
black men being brutally mistreated by
the police this is a bad example
you can find examples of black men being
brutally mistreated by police
you can find examples of white men being
brutally mistreated by the police
those situations do happen this happens
to be a particularly poor example but it
leads all the news
because the news people do not care your
journalistic experts do not care about
the particular circumstances
of every individual case they don't care
about due process they don't care about
what the actual evidence shows they
don't care about autopsy reports they
have a narrative and then there
must the narrative must be promoted the
impact of the coverage of the media
in cases like daniel pruitt's the
suggestion that this is a grave
miscarriage of justice by latisha james
this has an impact
on how people think about racism in the
united states
so there's a poll done by skeptic
magazine and they surveyed people
of various political persuasions on a
simple question how many black men
in america unarmed were killed by police
in 2019
right that is a simple objective
question how many people how many black
men who are unarmed were killed by the
police in 2019
now the actual statistic so you know
ranges based on the washington post
there are other reports that suggest
higher
it's some at a maximum it is 27 at a
maximum it is 27.
and you would know that if you listen to
shows like this one because we actually
focus in on the data we actually talk
about the fact that in a country with 40
million black americans
black americans are not a genocidal
existential risk from law enforcement
it's just a lie it is not true
but folks on the left like to promulgate
that narrative in fact that narrative is
so unbelievably popular that you had
literally 10 to 25 million people in the
streets repeating the lie
that america's police are systemically
racist over the summer
and you had some of those people going
and burning down the local neighborhood
so here is how americans how many
americans believe
black men were killed by the police
unarmed in 2019
and there's a serious differential in
terms of political persuasion here
so if you are very conservative you know
not very many black men are killed
unarmed by the police in fact 46 percent
of very conservative people knew that
the answer
is about 10. another 34
of very conservative americans said that
the answer was about 100.
okay so that's at least somewhat close
right i mean at least that's ballpark
a grand total of approximately
20 of very conservative people overall
thought that over a thousand black men
were killed unarmed in 2019 by the cops
now let's look at the very liberal crowd
the very liberal crowd
15.71 of very liberal americans
believed that about 10 black men were
killed unarmed by the cops in 2019
fully i'm not joking fully
31 thought that about 1 000
unarmed black men were killed by the
cops in 2019 another 14.29
thought that about 10 000 unarmed black
men were killed by the police in 2019
and 7.86 thought more than 10 000 were
killed
by the cops in 2019 which is utterly
crazy so when you add those three
numbers together
what you end up with is a majority a
majority
of very liberal people believe that over
1 000
black men were killed unarmed by the
cops in 2019 the actual answer
at a maximum is 27. so they're only off
by like two orders of magnitude okay
there's a reason
for that and the reason for that is the
media coverage and by the way
here's the big problem this holds true
for
normal liberal people not just very
liberal people normal liberal people
normal liberal people believe that
many many more unarmed black men were
killed than actually were killed
26.67 percent of normal liberal people
believe a thousand black men a year are
killed
unarmed by the cops another 12
think that at least 10 000 people
were killed by the cops unarmed black
every single year
now once you get to people who are
moderate and who don't believe the
narrative quite as much
you still end up with a huge percentage
of americans who believe that the number
is way higher than it is
right fully 41 of moderates believe that
about 100 people
were killed a year by the cops unarmed
and black and 16
still believe that about a thousand were
killed what you see is that as these
polls
get more conservative they get more
accurate right the more conservative
these folks are the more accurate they
are in fact
there's only one exception to this rule
and that is actually between very
conservative and conservative people
if you're just conservative and not very
conservative you're actually more
accurate on this question
about 86 of just conservative people
understood that the answer was below
100.
okay so here is the problem the
narrative has purchased
and the narrative is a lie black men are
not being routinely go
gunned down by cops unarmed every year
and this holds true throughout our
society
every time you hear about systemic
racism you should be asking for the data
what is the evidence
that a disparity is in fact
discrimination but people don't bother
people do not bother to actually answer
that question
okay so there is a there is a another
poll
statistic from skeptic okay and the
question was
in 2019 what percentage of people killed
by police total were black
the actual answer is about 30 percent
actually sorry about 25
about one quarter of all people killed
by the cops in 2019
or black the vast majority of those
people as we've just explored
we're armed or threatening the cops in
some way okay once again
once again the very liberal people get
this one completely wrong
they believe that 60 of all people
killed by the cops in 2019 were black
60 6 in 10 people killed by the cops
were black according to very liberal
people
according to liberal people 56 of people
who were killed by the cops in 2019 were
black total okay again
that is off by at least a factor of two
moderates
46 percent they they believe that 46
of people who are killed by the cops
were black in 2019.
conservatives were the closest once
again people who just consider
themselves conservative
were the closest on this score they say
that 37.8 percent of people killed by
the cops are black again the real number
is 25
so every single subgroup in american
life thought the number was higher than
it was
very conservative people thought 44.5
percent of people killed by the cops
were black
okay so here's the reality even among
conservatives the narrative has
purchased
because when you keep hearing over and
over and over that black men are being
gunned down and when the only stories
that you hear
are black men being shot by the police
as opposed to white people being shot by
the police or hispanic people being shot
by the police
well then you end up with a narrative
and the narrative often times is
extraordinarily false and here's the
thing
we live in a society where it's not
enough that
you hear the narrative you must parrot
the narrative
and if you don't parrot the narrative
you will be called out for being unwoke
you'll be called out for not being one
of the people who is sophisticated
one of the people who doesn't see you
you'll be it'll be suggested that you're
naive
you don't see through the system in fact
you are a
you are a pillar of the system you are a
person who makes this evil system
possible
unless you repeat a false narrative and
this has infused every aspect of our
culture
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did
go ahead and hit the subscribe button so
you stay up to date on all of our future
content